[Music]  20 years announced left pot best lookout  there was one day at a time  your parole will be satisfied in a few  months and then you can start to start  over  life isn't going the way I thought  [Music]  struggle with myself so much  in order to is my selfie  i am i can't understand you're gonna  have to speak up there's no emergency  I've lived in California almost 25 years  would you today at the ocean with me you  do know you can't take home abandoned  children right I could a doctor we know  about your record you're still a parolee  in the good state of California do you  have a bus to Wyoming round trip on one  way  [Music]  [Music]  swingley  [Music]  sorry it took me so long get here  you  [Music]  you